yeah I want to start out with quoting
Helen Keller that great woman that we
all admire and she had a statement that
is very profound and this statement is
that science has been able to find cures
for many evils but never the greatest
evil of all in human beings and that
evil is apathy so we know that apathy it
really costs us a lot especially in our
democracy and when we think of why
people do not get involved while they
did not become activists it's often that
people are so worn down with their own
promoted responsibilities it's and women
especially you know women they have so
many inhibitions many of them have
suffered so much trauma in their lives
so many aggressions in their lives and
so it's very hard for them to realize
that they have leadership capacities
that they can get out there and they
could change the world another thing
that many women we think that we have to
do everything that we are responsible
the only ones responsible for our
families and it is so hard for us to
delegate and just get others to help us
do the duties that we are responsible
for we feel embarrassed or we feel
guilty but we know that we have to make
this happen because if not we will never
have time to be able to volunteer to
help on these many causes that are not
facing us one of the areas that women
can give up a little bit of time and
that is in shopping okay
and especially when we go out there for
shopping for things that we don't even
need you know you never saw a hearse
whether you haul behind it we have to
live simply so that others can simply
live and when we think of the kind of
inheritance that we want to leave to our
children or our grandchildren think of
leaving them a legacy of justice this is
a legacy that they can not only imitate
but they can be proud of for the rest of
their lives if we leave them a lot of
material goods all they're going to do
is fight and they're going to hate each
other okay just remember that when we
think about what we're doing the other
thing that we have to do to liberate our
women eventually so that we can do the
kind of volunteer work that we need to
do to change this world is we have to
have a different kind of an education
for our young women unfortunately in our
societies around the world women are
taught to be victims women are not
taught that they are going to have to
defend themselves that they're going to
have to support themselves and they have
to protect themselves because you know
when we actually look at the animal
kingdom and we see who are the most
ferocious the male at the female we know
it's the female right so something went
wrong with us at the top of that animal
kingdom is women okay so I want to give
you an example of how I found my voice
and I was very fortunate in that I'm
when I was 25 years old I met a
gentleman named Fred Ross senior who
organized a chapter of a group called
the community service organization in my
hometown of Stockton California this was
a grassroots organization and I was
recruited to be a volunteer so one day
well we're in the sitting in the office
a farm worker comes in and he's
paralyzed he can hardly walk he has a
crutch and he needs help he needs
someone to help him go down to the
welfare office and make an application
so I volunteered to do that but when I
got to the welfare office they would not
let me make an application for this
gentleman so I didn't know what to do I
was at a loss
so I went back to the office and I told
mr. Ross they won't let me make an
application and he said to me very
sternly you go right back down to that
buffer office and you demand to see a
supervisor and you demand that they let
him make an application and I thought
wow I can do that so I thought about it
and I kind of what became my anxieties
and my fears I went down to the welfare
office and I demanded to see the
supervisor sure enough he came out and
they had to let mr. Reese
make an application for welfare and he
got his disability for himself and his
family
but that taught me a lesson that taught
me that I had a voice well mr. Ross also
taught many of us many of the things
including Cesar Chavez and many other
volunteers and he taught us not only
that we can make demands of people
especially all public officials and this
is something we should always keep in
mind every public official guess what
they work for us because we pay their
salaries with our taxes and they are
actually our servants some of them
turned out to be leaders but not all of
them okay so what sort of how we get it
we get it we get a leader out of there
the other thing that mr. Roscoe does is
that bullying is extremely important and
not just voting but going out there and
getting other people to vote getting
going door to door phone banking talking
to voters because many voters they have
a lot of doubts and they don't know how
to vote and unfortunately we know that
in many countries people are not allowed
to vote because we have voter
suppression and other countries like we
do here in the United States of America
but the thing is if we can get out
there's individuals and talk to people
so if we can remove their apathy and
make sure that they can vote so I want
to give you an example of a woman in our
foundation the dollars worth of
Foundation and just to show you that
sometimes people they have power but
they don't know it but once they find it
they do miraculous things so the
t-shirts Plaza is a immigrant from
Mexico only has a sixth grade education
and speaks very limited English
but she was very concerned because the
children at the Middle School in their
town called Weedpatch this is in
California Central Valley they couldn't
go out and play in the schoolyard
because the air quality is so bad in
this southern part of Kern County
California in our United States of
America so she and her husband went out
there and they passed a bond issue to
build a brand-new state-of-the-art
gymnasium for the publicans at their
middle school well that was a big
success then she heard a rumor that the
principal was going to end the breakfast
program for the farmworker children
because the principal thought that was
just too much paperwork so Leticia got
herself elected to the school board yeah
they kept the breakfast program and she
got rid of the principal so there were
other rumors about some corruption in
the local water district so Leticia got
herself elected does the water district
then she looked into all of the finances
of the water district and found there
was two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars missing from their bank account
so Leticia called in the grand jury and
several arrests have been made and this
is just an example of a woman you know
who never went to high school never went
to college but she found her power and
in addition she has recruited other
people in the community to also run for
public office and guess what they've all
gotten themselves elected so I think
that the Leticia she really embodies
something that Coretta Scott King said
and I want to share this with you
Coretta Scott King said we will never
have peace in the world until women take
power
now I have amended that statement to say
that we will never take a piece in the
world until feminists take power because
we know there is a difference right not
only that but if we want to define what
is a feminist a person who stands up for
reproductive rights for immigrants
rights for the environment for LGBT
rights and also for labor unions of
working people which also means that men
can also be feminists so when we think
of feminization we should also think of
how can we feminized the policies and
not only of our major countries the
wealthy countries like the United States
but all over the world our domestic and
foreign policies and one of the things
that we can do to stop wars and to have
peace is to make sure that the
wealthiest countries in the world also
help the developing countries now we did
this in the past after World War two
when Japan and Germany were devastated
after the war American United States of
America gave many tax dollars to those
two countries so that they could rebuild
our colonies the economies and rebuild
our corporations and we can do that
again and if we could think about how we
can help these other countries I want to
give an example of issues that we're
facing in the United States of America
for instance we know that right now we
have a lot of refugees from Central
America there at the border of the
United States why do people leave their
homes their beautiful homes that we go
to as tourists because they don't have
opportunities there and then we think
hmmm bananas how many Chileans have
bananas do we consume in the United
States every single day and throughout
the world
now do the people in Central America get
the profits from the Bennett bananas
that we consume no they don't the
profits go to us invent corporations
from the United States of America and we
think that this is wrong now if the
people in Central America where the
label gets
that money that we pay for bananas then
they wouldn't have to leave this homes
they would have to come as asylum
seekers to the borders of the United
States of America and then maybe many
children would not have to be separated
from their parents now we know that
there are countries of the world that
actually have free education and have
pre health care for all of the people in
their country in that country is Cuba
Cuba has health care for every one of
their citizens and they have a free
college education for every one of their
citizens there are 11 million citizens
now we think if we could poor country
like Cuba can have these kind of
resources and we know that their per
country then why can't some of the other
wealthier countries like the United
States of America do the same I think
that we can make that happen but we know
it's not going to happen until we are
the people of the United States of
America and people throughout the world
start making sure that they get public
officials elected to their governments
that really care about the constituents
they care about people that will commit
to make sure that the resources that
they have are going to be used for their
citizens and not to be used for war so
how do we make this happen we have to
get rid of the apathy we have to get
more people involved we know that we
cannot have a democracy within the
United States we're gonna have
democracies throughout the world unless
people participate so it is imperative
that all of us get out there and we say
get rid of the apathy get off of the
sidewalk come and join the March for
peace and justice like to make Coretta
Scott vision a reality to have peace in
the world we recently had midterm
elections here in the United States of
America and what did we see we saw that
so many more women young people people
of color LGBT folks were all elected to
public office and we know this happened
why because so many women were on the
March we had the woman smart in the
United States they had the women's
marches all over the world and so we now
see that we have this potential we have
this potential to get rid of the apathy
and it was yet everyone involved get
everyone committed then I think we can
make critic Scott's vision come true so
I want to just remind everybody it's
throughout the world one of the things
is we have power poor people have power
every citizen has power but in order to
achieve the peace that we all do we all
yearn for that we've all got to get
involved so what do we say can we do it
we say yes we can and in Spanish we say
si se puede
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]